俺なんかハチマキしてるみたいじゃん！！
黒チームかよw
後ろもちゃんとね、こうなってるんで。
とあるメッセージを頂きました。
やりましょう！！！
ぜひやりましょう！
フェットチーネグミのイタリアンピーチ味と、じゃがりこのたらこバター味。
俺もね、ちょっとよくわかんないんだよ。
これを混ぜることによって何味になるかっていうのはまだ聞いてないから
わかんないわけですよ。
これはね、実に興味深いね。
フィットチーネグミは、まあまあ美味しいんですよ。
これ美味しいんですけど。
やべ、あご外れた。
なんかすっぱいもん食べるとあご外れるんすよ。
ツイッターで来ただけなんで本当にこれがどんな味になるか僕も知らないし
皆も知らないでしょ？
やったことない…
こともない人もいるかもしれません
それは俺にもわかんないけど
俺は初めてだから
早速もうパパッとやっちゃいましょう
あのね、ちょっとね、言うとね
実は昨日から今日までマミーが家に来ててね
いろいろとね、ちょっと将来のことを話し合ったわけですよ。
こうやってなんかちゃんと協力してくれる家族がいるってことはとても有難いことです。
ありがとっ！
じゃあ早速やっていきましょう
はいこちらです
フェットチーネグミとたらこバター味っていう
こっち(じゃがりこ)がLサイズなんで(フェットチーネグミ)2つでやります
髪型が気になる
もうやだ早くこの髪の毛でも直したい！！！！
こういう感じかな？
ちょっと食べます。いただきます！
あっ…
えっ？
なにこれ？
えっ？アクエリアス？違うな…
なんだこれ？
なんか、あの口じゃ説明できないんですけど…
いや、できるわ。
口で説明できるんですけど
なんか、ブツブツブツブツって感じでした。
ん？
何？なんだ、これなんて説明すればいいんだろ…
なんかね、味的な変化ではないんですよ。
味的には…何だろう、すりりんごみたいな感じかな？
りんごみたいな味になります。
ただ不思議なのは
なんか口の中、ブツブツブツってなるんすよ。
え、待ってでも
俺のこの味覚が合ってるか分かんないからちょっとググろう。
フェットチーネグミ、イタリアンピーチ
たらこバター
え、待ってネットの情報がない…
じゃがりフェットチーネじゃない。
無いな、無い。
無いぞ！！
たぶんネットに情報はないですこれ。
これ大変だ。
大発見だよ
僕の味覚ですよ。
僕はですけど
この2つを一緒に食べると
うん
え、俺、待って俺…
自分、だれ？自分だれ？
知らんわ。
俺の味覚はみなさんご存知の通り
信用できるものではないので
ひょっとしたら個人差があるかもしれませんね
だって俺の言った味になるかどうかっていうのはわからないからね
このリプ送ってくれた子は何味って言おうとしたんだろうな
よかったら皆さんもやってみてください。
俺は、りんご味だと思ったし
なんか変なブツブツがこうあったね。
ちょっと皆分かんない
俺の舌は信用できないから
よかったら皆さんの意見もお聞かせいただけるとありがたきございます。
じゃあな！
卵の殻。